اذا كما قلت احمد تطورات تتسارع في مسار
المشاورات الثنائيه بين طهران واشنطن
انفتاح في العلاقات بعد سنوات من التوتر
والهدف بعث مرحله جديده اساسها توسيع
مساحات المصلحه الاستراتيجيه لكلا الطرفين
المفاوضات التي باتت تخرج من طبع السريه
غيرت معها موقف اسرائيل التي لطالما رفضت
اي اتفاق تتوصل اليه واشنطن وايران حيث ان
عدوا بارزا بالكنس الاسرائيلي قال ان
بلاده قد تقبل التوصل الى تفاهم بين طهران
وواشنطن اذا ما تضمن ذلك اشرافا صارما على
برنامج طهران النووي وجاء هذا بعد ان شدد
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي في وقت سابق على
ان بلاده لن تكون ملزمه باي تسويه سيتم
التوصل اليها بين امريكا وايران
تحدثت مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكي واكدت
على موقفنا الثابت العوده الى الاتفاق
النووي مع ايران لن توقف برنامج طهران
النووي بل ستسمح لايران فقط بتوجيه
الاموال حتى بمبالغ كبيره الى اذرعها في
المنطقه شددت على ان اي اتفاق مع ايران لن
يلزم اسرائيل
طبعا الموقف الايراني كان ثابتا ايضا حيث
اشار المرشد الايراني على ان الغرب لن
يتمكن من منع ايران من تطوير اسلحه اذا
ارادت ذلك
يجب عدم المساس بالبنيه التحتيه لصناعه
النوويه خلال هذه السنوات قام المديرون
والمسؤولون والناشطون في هذه الصناعه
باعمال مهمه وانشاوا بنيه تحتيه كبيره قد
ترغبون في عقد اتفاقيات في بعض المجالات
النوويه لا توجد مشكله اتفقوا لكن لا
ينبغي المساس بالبنت التحتيه
التجميد النووي مقابل تجميد العقوبات
معادله جديده لحل القضيه بين الاطراف
واساس التوصل لاتفاق ملزمين الذي بموجبه
ستقلص طهران برنامجها النووي مقابل تخفيف
العقوبات الامريكيه عليها
اشارت بدورها لمفاوضات سريه بين الاطراف
فواشنطن تحاول الحصول على تنازلات النوويه
من ايران مقابل الافراج عن الاموال
المحجوبه كما ان صحيفه فاشل تايمز كشفت في
وقت سابق على ان المبعوث الاميركي الخاص
للشؤون الايرانيه التقى في نيويورك مرات
عده خلال الايام الاخيره بمندوب ايران
الدائم لدى الامم المتحده وفق مراقبين
سيناريو التفاهم المؤقت هو الاكثر احتمالا
بالنسبه للنوويه الايراني حتى قبيل
الانتخابات الامريكيه المقبله على امل
مواصله المباحثات وتحويل التفا همات الى
توافقات في حال فوز الديمقراطيين
بالرئاسيه الامريكيه المقبله وفي حال فشل
المفاوضات الجاريه في التوصل الى تفاهم
سيناريو الفشل سيتمثل في حرص الجانبين على
ابقاء قنوات التواصل قائمه بانتظار فرصه
جديده لاستئناف المفاوضات
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات